kim kardashian says kanye west is
causing her emotional distress in the
estranged couple's latest divorce filing
i'm just rolling with it in new court
docks obtained by e.t the 41-year-old
skim's founder says that she does very
much desire to be divorced telling the
court that kanye has been putting a lot
of misinformation about their private
matters and co-parenting on social media
which has caused kim emotional distress
it is what it is of course all this
comes after yay publicly slammed kim on
instagram hurling a variety of
accusations at her including that she
didn't provide the address for their
daughter chicago's birthday party put
security on him when he was playing with
his son had him take a drug test after
the party and that their eldest daughter
north is on tick-tock against his will
[Music]
no no
following the rapper's claims kim
responded on instagram expressing her
desire to resolve their issues privately
social media is such a great tool but of
course you need boundaries i think
everyone does and she echoes all that in
the new court docs claiming that she's
asked kanye to keep their divorce
proceedings as private as possible but
he has not done so i'll voice my opinion
when i think that there's something that
you know is maybe done wrong or even if
the messaging's right maybe it the
communication isn't quite there a source
previously told et that kanye has been
lashing out on social media because he's
really hurt and feeling detached from
the people he loves the most in the
world i'm just extremely happy can you
tell by my face
quote this is his way of fighting to get
his family back just do something for my
heart of course kim filed for divorce
from the grammy winner back in february
2021 after six years of marriage in the
filing she asked for joint legal and
physical custody of the couple's four
children north saint chicago and psalm
and a source told et at the time that
the rapper was fine with the joint
custody agreement and the two were
committed to co-parenting we are so
blessed to have the best support system
and the best family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through then in
december kim filed to be declared
legally single and to drop west from her
name emphasizing her desire to terminate
their marital status and writing in the
docs there is no question that the
marriage of the parties is no longer
viable quite simply kim has quote no
desire to reconcile and they both
deserve the opportunity to build new
lives at the end of the day life is
about being happy kim is currently
awaiting the judge's approval and is
expected to get an answer at a scheduled
hearing in march but earlier this month
yay filed legal docs objecting to kim's
request that she be legally declared
single stating that he wants his assets
protected via a set of conditions that
kim allegedly has rejected
[Music]